this video is sponsored by Legal Zoom
more on Legal Zoom at the end of the
video
hey wisecrack jared again now I don't
know about you but every time a new
Christopher Nolan movie comes out I
happily shell out my hard-earned 25
bucks for a sweet IMAX 70-millimeter
experience there are few directors today
that can meld thought-provoking
philosophy with big-budget spectacle but
no one well he makes it look as easy as
spinning a top now instead of focusing
on one particular Nolan film we're gonna
take a step back and look at his entire
filmography because throughout all 10 of
Nolan's movies certain themes keep
coming back in fact there's so much to
discuss we've pulled the ultimate
Hollywood move today's Christopher Nolan
video will be the first of three on the
director now don't worry we're not
pulling a hobbit and extending a
children's book into a 7-hour trilogy
think of this instead if you will as our
Lord of the Rings there's just so much
great stuff to say about Nolan that we
have to make three videos in order to do
his work justice so sit back in your
recliner chair and welcome to this epic
wisecrack IMAX 70 millimeter
presentation of the philosophy of
Christopher Nolan part 1 and of course
spoilers ahead Christopher Nolan's films
can be broken down into three distinct
phases the self society and the universe
the first phase will discuss the self
includes Nolan's early work following
memento insomnia and the prestige as
well as inception these films questioned
the nature of personhood can we ever
truly know someone else can we know
ourselves can our own thoughts be
trusted hell what even is a person to
better understand how these questions
develop in Nolan's work we're first
gonna have to learn a little something
about what French philosopher Paul Recor
calls the hermeneutics of suspicion or
as the cool kids say H OS hermeneutics
studies how people interpret texts think
of how a biblical verse can be
interpreted any number of ways Christ's
crucifixion could be thought of as an
allegorical moral or even literal story
hermeneutics looks at all these
different interpretations focusing on
the methodologies people use to justify
their interpretations and it's not just
biblical texts legal literary
philosophical pretty much any text you
can think of falls within hermeneutics
heck I mean wisecrack is BAE
just one giant site dedicated to
hermeneutics all we do is interpret text
film television literature video games
you name it but record questions these
so-called interpretations identifying a
group of outside-the-box philosophers
committed to drawing out less visible
and flattering truths Recor called this
group the school of suspicion which sort
of sounds like an erotic French thriller
starring Charlotte Rampling and Lew
Devine San yay but unfortunately it's
just three dudes with facial hair
Friedrich Nietzsche Karl Marx and
Sigmund Freud
according to recore these figures and
the lineage they inspired were committed
to unmasking the lies and illusions of
consciousness they circumvented
self-evident meanings in text focusing
on what wasn't said and the
contradictions within all to decode a
true disguised meaning so while
religious stories like Christ's
resurrection may seem to be about how
man achieves salvation for the school of
suspicion these stories disguised a
hidden meaning mark stated that the true
purpose of religious narratives were to
make the misery of life more endurable
Nietzsche unmasked religion as the
refuge for the weak giving purpose to
the mentally fragile and Freud thought
that religion was an illusion that
substituted one's wish for a father with
God now yes hermeneutics of suspicion
typically only applies to texts but it
can be used more broadly to refer to any
so-called interpretation we hold as
self-evident and what's more
self-evident and well ourselves yes you
YouTube viewer watching this video with
your 8 tabs open and fidget spinner in
hand what we drink watch where think
believe all inform how we interpret
ourselves and others much like the h OS
no one questions the conclusions that
come from standard interpretations he
confounds our assumed knowledge
challenging our presuppositions to
reveal deeper disguised truths about who
the hell we really are Nolan's films are
always about that suspicious relation
between our subjective reality and the
idea of an objective reality now this
might sound like idealism to the
philosophically inclined among you but
we're not arguing that Nolan dismisses
any external reality but rather he
embraces a critical disposition toward
the accepted notions of the self
take christopher nolan's debut following
the black-and-white indie follows Billy
a struggling writer who obsessively
watches people from afar to get
inspiration for his novel one day he
follows a well-dressed thief named Cobb
known about one after he robbed a house
Cobb quickly notices Billy watching but
instead of running away or attacking the
stalker he invites Billy to join in on
his robberies just to now see Cobb is
far less interested in stealing precious
items than in figuring out the lives of
people through their possessions
breaking and entering someone's life
funny how they really are both Cobb and
Billy interpret and construct their own
images of people Billy by following
strangers around and Cobb by breaking
into people's homes and rifling through
their belongings but Nolan immediately
questions that these conclusions hold
any merit suggesting you can't rely on
appearances and possessions to define a
person as Cobb himself says when
burglarizing a house take it away
for Cobb violating a person's property
forces his victims to reevaluate
themselves when the possessions people
hold dear are taken away or altered it's
in effect causes them to question their
identity Nolan also questions people's
reliance on appearances Cobb urges Billy
to cut his hair and on his same suits
which Billy immediately does because he
wants to be just like his mentor but
this is all a setup the blonde woman is
working with Cobb to frame Billy the
earlier break in and make over just a
long con on the poor writer
Billy's own presuppositions of Cobb are
revealed to be false a far more
dastardly intent lurking beneath his
friendly smile and mentorship he doesn't
like
no one's suspicion towards using
possessions and appearance to define
others carries over to his next feature
memento the film's protagonist Leonard
suffers from anterograde amnesia and
relies on a series of possessions
photographs notes and tattoos to remind
himself of who the people around him are
and whether they can be trusted Leonard
puts complete faith in these items
depending on them exclusively to guide
his actions he trusts Natalie because
his notes
tell him to he kills Teddy because again
his notes tell him to use them on he
believes the car parked outside is his
because he has a photograph that tells
him so my car a car oh you're in a
playful mood but of course these
mementos aren't nearly as reliable as
Leonard believes you don't even know my
name
Teddy picture Nolan in true h OS fashion
creates drama by throwing suspicion
toward the validity of text in this case
photographs notes and tattoos how can we
trust something we read if the source
itself is questionable
truth is Natalie can't be trusted that
car parked out front actually doesn't
belong to Leonard and Teddy well he's
not the guy Leonard should kill it all
Leonard may say well I go on facts not
recommendations but thank you but if the
truths these facts are based on are
incorrect then what use are they no one
constantly draws a distinction between
Leonard's subjective reality and the
idea of objective truth well what we
were trying to do is if essentially
present a an idea of the tension between
our subjective view of the world the
subjective way in which we have to
experience life and then our faith in an
object of reality beyond that in
Leonard's subjective view he's a husband
avenging the rape and murder of his wife
after a break-in but as the film reveals
his wife actually survived this initial
attack it was Leonard who accidentally
killed his wife forgetting he had
already given her her insulin shot
moreover Leonard actually already caught
and murdered his wife's rapist over a
year ago he uses text to trick himself
into believing that this ideal
revenge mission still exists you don't
want the truth you make up your own
truth like you police fire it was
complete when I gave it to you who took
out the 12 pages you will probably know
it wasn't me see it was you why would I
do that to create a puzzle you could
never solve
Leonard conditions himself to believe in
the lies he's created to the point where
even his own long-term memories are
fabricated he substitutes the story of
Sammy Jenkins for his own so he doesn't
have to live with the guilt of
accidentally murdering his wife no one
here extends the hermeneutics of
suspicion from simple text Leonard's
unreliable notes to leonard himself his
own false memories I lie to myself to be
happy in your case teddy yes I will
this suspicion continues into Nolan's
third feature insomnia we're momento
Leonard is an unreliable narrator who's
unable to discern reality from his own
fiction
Insomnia's chief protagonist detective
wil dormer seems to be the opposite he's
reliable intelligent and perceptive
but if memento focused on a broken man
attempting to rebuild his sense of self
insomnia takes the counter approach
showing how even the most rock-solid guy
likes a an Al Pacino can crumble into
self-doubt with just a little push sea
madness as you know is like gravity all
it takes all that ledger we'll get to
you in part two anyway after will
mistakenly shoots his partner in the fog
the guilt of the event triggers intense
psychological confusion and well
insomnia he hallucinates his dead
partner rooms seemed to distort around
will and everyday noises become
blisteringly irritating later will
hallucinates that he actually did see
his partner in the fog and that he
deliberately shot him unlike memento
insomnia provides no clear explanation
about what is true did will deliberately
shoot his partner or was it just an
accident the answer who knows
Nolan yet again extends the hermeneutics
of suspicion now questioning reality
itself he implies it's much more
complicated than just accepting either
pure objectivity or subjective idealism
perhaps we can't ever be sure of the
world around us by the end of insomnia
we'll doesn't even know if he
deliberately shot his partner or not did
you mean to shoot HAP
I don't know
the prestige is pretty much Nolan's
greatest hits as he tackles all the
hermeneutics of suspicion from his
earlier work the film is told through a
series of journals many of which are
fake once again casting suspicion on
good old texts all of the film's
magicians use disguises to mask their
tricks the great Chung Ling soo pretends
to be a [ __ ] Alfred Borden wears
disguises to mask that he has a twin and
both Alfred and his friend me Robert
Angie R repeatedly pretend to be
audience members like in following and
memento appearances can't be trusted and
the self is constantly put into doubt
even Alfred's own wife doesn't know his
secret confused that her husband could
be so loving one day and so cold the
next unaware of the existence of her
husband's twin I love you
today it's not true today you don't mean
it no one uses magic yet again to
question subjective reality versus the
idea of objective truth from the
audience's subjective point of view the
bird really does disappear and then
reappear but in reality there were
actually two twin birds one dead beneath
the table the other reappearing in the
magician's hand fool just as mementos
Leonard prefers to live in the illusion
of his manipulated subjective reality
the audience too prefers illusion over
truth they don't want to know how Robert
literally duplicates himself each night
murdering his double and a water tank
beneath the stage they'd much rather
live under the lie that Robert
disappears and then suddenly reappears
on the opposite end of the theater
people actually believe the things I did
on stage they wouldn't clap that
screaming as the filmmaker no one views
himself like these magicians he plays
with illusion and misdirection to keep
the audience guessing we know that we're
watching a movie a projection on a
screen and illusion but we don't really
want to know this truth so we revel in
the imaginary world that Nolan has
crafted this is what Nolan ultimately
wants to affect the audience through
trick
for him the truth deep down is that we
prefer the imaginary over reality the
audience knows the truth
[Music]
then you don't know what
[Music]
in you have to seize
Nolan's suspicion towards reality
climaxes in Inception a film where every
single thing is put into doubt that guy
who looks like Tom Berenger well that's
actually Tom Hardy can't trust your eyes
that thought you just had it's actually
been implanted by Leonardo DiCaprio
can't trust yourself your children
waiting to play outside actually it's
all a dream maybe can't trust anything
exceptions protagonists dream thief Cobb
no not that one
can barely discern his reality from a
dream to the point where it doesn't even
matter in Cobbs supposed reality he's on
the run chased by goons with guns
through Byzantine pathways in Cobbs
supposed a dream he's well still on the
run chased by goons with guns through
Byzantine pathways Chinese to run the
globe by anonymous corporations and
police forces the weather projections
persecute the dreamer admit it don't
believe in one reality no one
deliberately draws this parallel to
showcase how muddled the two are put
simply there is no difference between
dream and reality because subjectively
Cobb can't tell the difference such is
the fate for Cobbs wife mom she believes
that her reality is still a dream and to
wake up she must kill herself possessed
by an idea this one very simple idea
that changed everything that our world
wasn't real that she needed to wake up
to come back to reality
but what if malls actually right what if
Cobb has been dreaming the whole time
what if you're wrong what if I'm what's
real no definitive answer is ever given
which is exactly Nolan's point in the
end only the question remains that lasts
indelible image of that goddamn
spinnings hop spinning but just slightly
wavering provides no definitive answer
as to if Cobb is dreaming or awake only
further proving that in the end there is
no truth no reality only the suspicions
thereof well at least until we get to
part three through each of Nolan's early
films he cast doubt on appearances on
possessions on others on ourselves on
our thoughts and finally on reality but
if you can't trust anybody else and you
can't trust yourself and wholly you
can't even trust the reality surrounding
you then how the hell does society
function
how can people come together and form a
stable working unit given the
foundational bedrock is so wonky this is
the question Nolan explores through his
Dark Knight trilogy which we'll explore
in the next part of our own wisecrack
Nolan trilogy thanks for watching guys
peace no one is a master at making you
question your sanity but there's no
reason your legal needs should make you
feel that way
LegalZoom is the smart way to handle all
your legal essentials and they're giving
wisecrack fans 15% off their purchase
whether you're setting up a new business
or planning family matters they'll help
you breeze through the process like it's
nothing
LegalZoom eliminates the guesswork of
trying to track down an attorney you
trust calculating how much your legal
work will cost and having to drag
yourself to a lawyer's office LegalZoom
works with a network of independent
attorneys to help you with all sorts of
projects the formation of your company
wills and trusts trademarks and patents
contracts and more when we decided to do
wisecrack full time the most important
step was making sure our business was
set up right
separating personal stuff from the
company and navigating all the
intricacies of state and local laws can
be a huge pain but LegalZoom offers the
services and resources to make sure you
get it done right
over to legalzoom.com / wisecrack at the
link in the description below and bring
all your questions about starting a
business planning a family or copyright
and trademark stuff you'll get 15% off
your purchase just for being a fan of
what we do
thanks to Legal Zoom for sponsoring this
video that's all for now wisecrack don't
forget to subscribe to help us reach 2
million subscribers and ring that Bell
see don't miss a thing
peace guys
[Music]